news election headquarters right here
in new york
and we are going to get to our 4 p.m
show in just a moment but brian we are
going to toss it back
over to the president who is still
speaking at this house yes as cbs wraps
up the coverage 8 news now is going to
bring you right back to
president trump we'll listen in i went
to school there and i know
a lot about it hasn't changed a long
time ago and hasn't changed
it's gotten worse in pennsylvania
partisan democrats have allowed ballots
in the state to be received three days
after the election
and we think much more than that and
they are counting those
without even postmarks or any
identification
whatsoever so you don't have postmarks
you don't have identification
there have been a number of disturbing
irregularities across the
nation our campaign has been denied
access to observe
any counting in detroit detroit is
another place
and i wouldn't say has the best
reputation for
election integrity poll workers in
michigan were duplicating ballots
but when our observers attempted to
challenge the activity those poll
workers
jumped in front of the volunteers to
block their views so that they couldn't
see what they were doing
and it became a little bit dangerous
one major hub for counting ballots in
detroit covered up the windows again
with large pieces of cardboard and
so they wanted to protect and block the
counting area they didn't want anybody
seeing the county though these were
observers who were
legal observers that were supposed to be
there in detroit
there were hours of unexplained delay in
delivering many of the votes for
counting
the final batch did not arrive until
four in the morning
and uh even though the polls closed at
eight o'clock so they brought it in
and the batches came in and nobody knew
where they came from
we've also been denied access to observe
in critical places in georgia
and multiple swing states counting was
halted for hours
and hours on election night with results
withheld from
major democrat-run locations only to
appear
later and they certainly appeared and
they all had the name biden on them or
just about all
i think almost all they all had the name
biden on them
which is a little strange i challenge
joe and every democrat to clarify that
they only want
legal votes because they talk about
votes and i think they should use the
word legal legal votes we want
every legal vote counted and i want
every legal vote counted we want
openness and transparency
no secret count rooms no mystery ballots
no
illegal votes being cast after election
day
you have election day and the laws are
very strong on that you have an election
day
and they don't want votes cast after
election day and
they want the process to be an honest
one it's so important
we want an honest election we want an
honest count
and we want honest people working back
there because it's a very important job
so
that's the way this country is going to
win that's the way the united states
will win
and we think we will win the election
very easily we think there's going to be
a lot of litigation because we have so
much evidence so much proof
and it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen like this and i i
tell you i would
i have been talking about this for many
months with all of you
and i've said very strongly that mail-in
ballots are going to end up being a
disaster
small elections were a disaster small
very easy to handle
elections were disastrous
this is a large scale version and it's
getting worse and worse every day we're
hearing
stories that are horror stories absolute
horror stories
and we can't let that happen to the
united states of america it's not a
question of who wins
republican democrat joe myself
we can't let that happen to our country
we can't be disgraced by having
something like this happen
so it will be hopefully cleared up maybe
soon i hope soon
but it'll probably go through a process
a legal process and
as you know i've claimed certain states
and he's claiming states so we can both
claim the states but ultimately i have a
feeling judges are going to have to rule
but there's been a lot of shenanigans
and we can't stand for that in our
country
thank you very much
[Music]
and you're listening there to president
donald trump alleging voter fraud in
several states saying this will go to
the highest court of the land brian
one of the things the president was
pointed out was the polls and the fact
that
many of the polls had mr biden up eight
nine points obviously a much tighter
election
as votes are still being counted pointed
out the incorrect nature of the polls
and talking about alleged shenanigans of
course cbs news is fact checking all
those statements but we did want to
bring you the president live here on 8
news now